Alexis Moussine-Pouchkine: Hello and
welcome back to Devoxx 2014.
I'm here with
Ludovic Champenois,
and we're here to talk about
something called Managed VM.
Ludo, welcome.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Welcome.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: And
actually, Managed VM
is something I've heard
about a long time ago.
Well, not that long ago,
but it's been in the works
for a little while.
And it kind of
changes the game, I
think, for App Engine
users or the people that
looked at App Engine
awhile back and maybe
it didn't fit their needs.
So maybe, I think,
Managed VM is a reason
they should look at it, and
of course, for everybody else,
it opens new possibilities.
So walk us through some of that.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Managed
VM was announced last week
in San Francisco,
so it's brand new.
MALE SPEAKER: So everybody
has access to this now?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS:
Everybody has access to it.
Before, we were running a
private trusted tester trial,
but now everybody
can try Managed VM.
Managed VM is really
App Engine V2.
This is a new App
Engine 2.0, which
is based on all the
cloud platform features
that we launched over
the last few years.
So it's basically you keep the
App Engine model, very simple,
just work on your
application, you deploy it
and it scales automatically.
We do failover.
We manage for it.
MALE SPEAKER: So keep all
the goodness of App Engine.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS:
You keep everything
that was a value of App
Engine as we know it today.
And then, in order to run in
the old Google data centers,
App Engine had to give you some
restrictions because you cannot
write to a file system, you
could not use native code
because, guess what, with
native code you can explore
the environment.
MALE SPEAKER: So
for Java developers,
there was a [INAUDIBLE].
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Some people
were not very happy with this.
I agree, but with
value added on terms
of the scalability
of the platform,
you had to give
away a few features.
So App Engine v2,
or Managed VMs,
is exactly removing
all those restrictions.
Basically, you run a container.
You have heard at
Devoxx this week,
everybody's taking
about containers.
MALE SPEAKER: It's kind
of a trending thing, yes.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: So a
container is a new WAR format.
It's a new unit of deployment,
but it's not a new Java.
It's your unit of processing,
whether it's a JVM or a JVM
plus native code that you
want to call because you want
to access a native image
library, for example,
or a PDF generator,
et cetera, et cetera.
So you can keep the simplicity
of App Engine, deploy
it to Managed VM,
and, for example,
use native code or AWG or--
MALE SPEAKER: All
the things that
were forbidden, that you
could not use before.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: While
upgrading to Managed VM,
we also upgraded all the
Servlet specifications
we are using in
classic, and now you
can do Servlet 3.1
with annotation.
We're extremely
efficient in terms
of processing those
annotations at the SDK time,
before we deploy the
container to the cloud.
Managed VM is based
on Compute Engine,
so it's App Engine running
on top of Compute Engine
and running inside of VM,
but instead of giving you
pure access to the
VM, we are running
a Docker system inside this VM.
So what you really
develop locally
on your desktop
is a Docker image,
so you test it with
Docker containers,
and then once you're
OK, you can deploy it
to the cloud using the
same exact image you
have been using.
MALE SPEAKER: Which is part
of the value of Docker,
is to be able to have the
same exact environment
in development and
production, no longer
it works on my machine.
But walk us through a little
bit for the developer what
it means.
Are they exposed to Docker
as such on the client side?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: No.
If you do nothing except
changing one line in your App
Engine weblet XML, and
the line is VM true.
So basically, you
declare to the system,
I want to run in a
VMware environment.
Then the SDK will
create the Docker image,
instantiate a Docker
container for you,
and you are not
exposed to docker.
MALE SPEAKER: So
the App Engine SDK
or the cloud SDK actually
extracts all that.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS:
Same commands as before.
You run or you deploy your
application, and underneath,
we will use a Docker system
running on your desktop,
and we will execute this
Docker container for you.
This is the out of the box
experience for App Engine V2
or Managed VM.
One line in your code,
and then suddenly, you're
running in the
Docker environment.
So now, once you are running
in this Docker environment,
we give you, again,
access to the full JVM,
but we give you access
to other runtimes.
So obviously, we have
Java, Python, and Go,
like App Engine previously.
MALE SPEAKER: Even more
recent versions of Java?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS:
Java 7 out of the box,
but if you want to start
customizing those runtimes,
you can as well, because you
can edit a Docker file, which
is a unit of description of
what is your Docker container.
Instead of downloading
the open JDK 7,
you can download
JDK 8 if you want,
or even JDK 9, or even your
own build of JDK if you want,
and this Managed VM will run
with this new JVM if you want.
MALE SPEAKER: But
you were about to say
that we can have also
brand new runtimes.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS:
Of course, we
can customize all the ways
JVM running in this container,
and we can also
explore new runtime.
So for example, we have a
custom runtime called NodeJS.
I guess NodeJS is extremely
popular for mobile developers,
mobile back ends.
We kept the simplicity
of App Engine.
We provide JavaScript
or NodeJS App Engine
APIs for datastore,
memcache, [INAUDIBLE].
All the APIs that are part
of the App Engine ecosystem
can be accessed from
a NodeJS application.
And suddenly you have
a brand new runtime,
but using the same unit of
deployment, unit of execution
and management in App Engine
so that we can scale you
to many more VMs, depending
on the traffic you have.
MALE SPEAKER: So
NodeJS is even newer.
So Managed VM allowed for
something like NodeJS to exist.
This is something
that Google worked
on that is being offered.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Yes.
It's still beta, but we did
all the API bindings for NodeJS
for App Engine.
You can use also Google
Cloud APIs as well.
So if you want to access
Cloud Storage or mapreduce,
the big data capabilities
of the cloud platform,
you can also use that from
a generic NodeJS library
that you add packet JSON to
describe that you depend on it.
MALE SPEAKER: Any other runtime?
I think Dart is supported
on the server as well.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: We have
dart as well because Dart
has been very, very
popular on the client side,
and guess what, it's a full
feature server side language
as well.
The Dart team worked with
us to deliver a Dart runtime
for App Engine as well.
And same, instead of using
Java or Node, you use Dart,
but the cloud SDK we are using
for your local development is
the same.
Basically, it's just
a Docker file saying,
I want to use a
Java image or I want
to use a NodeJS image
or a Dart image.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, great.
So I guess Google in
the cloud is embracing
Docker, obviously,
trying to [INAUDIBLE]?
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: We
are embracing containers.
I mean, we have been
using containers forever.
App Engine in 2008 was running
in a [INAUDIBLE] group isolated
environment in the cloud.
We cannot really talk about it,
but this is how we were able
to scale App Engine
as we know it today.
The nice thing about
Docker is finally,
the entire world is
recognizing that containers
is the way to go.
We are very happy that the
Docker ecosystem is there
because it's not only Google
doing private technology.
It's the entire community
actively participating
in the Docker ecosystem,
which is great.
MALE SPEAKER: And Docker
is hitting the sweet spot
of being relevant both to
developers and to production,
and I think that's very useful.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Exactly.
This is the perfect
model for the future
of cloud for all
the cloud providers.
MALE SPEAKER: And so
you mentioned also
that, obviously, Google is
very invested in Docker.
We're also investing in things,
I would say, on top of Docker,
things like [INAUDIBLE].
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: But
that is a subject
of another interview
we'll have soon.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS:
We have a continuum
from bare metal VMs
to cluster management,
and then the other side of
the spectrum, which is I
only focus on my
application, I deploy it
and Google, please do
the management for me.
MALE SPEAKER: And the scaling
and the load balancing
and all of that.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: And
from those two extremes,
you create a brand new
VM through Managed VM,
we have a spectrum of
capabilities and technology
that you can, if you
want, start using.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So Managed VM, now in beta.
Anybody can use it.
Try it out.
I think if you've
looked at App Engine
before, you probably
should look at it again.
It removes pretty much
all of the restrictions
you might have come across.
So thank you, Ludo.
LUDOVIC CHAMPENOIS: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: And
looking forward
to the feedback of
people using that.